revenons donc à l'ébola aux États-Unis
un hôpital du connecté cut a annoncé
qu'il examinait un patient admis hier
soir qui présente des symptômes pouvant
être ceux de la fièvre Ébola et 6
employés d'une compagnie aérienne eu
sont placés sous surveillance ils
avaient voyagé avec la 2è infirmière de
Dallas infectée là par le virus alors
Christian est à Dallas sur place
parle-nous d'abord de ce patient au con
ou tard hier soir ce patient été admis
dans un hôpital du connectecute c'est un
étudiant qui aurait récemment voyagé en
Afrique alors il s'est présenté
effectivement avec des symptômes de
l'ébola de la fièvre entre autres et ce
matin les autorités de cet hôpital du
connectcut ont confirmé effectivement
qu'il était sous observation mais pour
l'instant là il y a pas de confirmation
que il s'agit d'un cas là d'Ebola je
vous parle maintenant de ces employés de
la compagnie fly Frontier qui sont
actuellement sous observation vous savez
en ce moment il y a un débat euh jeun
VIè aux États-Unis sur la politique de
quarantaine de mise en quarantaine qui
est complètement remise en question et
qui semble-t-il avait été on avait tenté
sous l'administration Bush de refaire le
le point l'administration Obama n'avait
pas suivi les recommandations de
l'administration Bou là il y a un flou
artistique alors oui il y a ces employés
ces membres d'équipage qui sont en
quarantaine mais euh en ce moment on est
très inquiet sur cette politique de de
mise en quarantaine parce que
semble-t-il que c'est du cas par cas et
en ce moment ça prendrait là les
directives là pour l'ensemble du pays
pour faire face à ces problèmes liés à
l'Ebola donc employé sous surveillance
parce qu'ils auraient ils ont été en
contact avec cette infirmière de Dallas
qui a
voyagé alors qu'elle était atteinte
d'bola pourquoi d'ailleurs cette deuxème
infirmière qui a été infectée à
l'hôpital de las a-t-elle été transférée
à Atlanta
sais écoutez ça c'est c'est pas clair je
viève selon Associated Press qui selon
un témoin du gouvernement qui a dit que
le Centre pour la prévention des maladie
infectieuse à Atlanta aurait donné le
feu vert à cette infirmière pour voyager
et bon comment se fait-il que une
personne qui était sous observation une
personne qui a soigné un des patients
qui est mort de l'ébola ici au
presbyarian Hospital à Daras a eu droit
de monter à bord de d'un appareil à
l'intérieur duquel se trouvaient 132
passagers ça personne ne le sait comment
se fait-il que elle même comme
infirmière c'est permis alors qu'elle
savait qu'elle avait de la fièvre de
monter à bord de cet appareil ça non
plus on n pas de réponse ce que je peux
vous dire et je vous laisse sur une
bonne note c'est que ce caméraman de NBC
qui a contracté la maladie en Afrique se
porte de jour en jour de mieux en mieux
alors voilà c'est au moins une bonne
nouvelle dans ce dossierl Christi l en
direct de Dallas ou Texas merci beaucoup
au revoir